hi Isabelle how are you hi I'm great
thanks how are you uh we're doing
terrific we were told this might be a
difficult connection because you're
coming from kind of a rural area is that
right I am I'm in Appalachia I'm in
southern West Virginia wow Souther yeah
the internet's body okay but you you
have internet well clearly um I don't I
don't have internet or sell service at
my house so um my church was kind enough
to let me use the office here okay so
you have no no internet no sell service
at home you drove to your church and
you're using their self service that you
can talk to us right now from West
Virginia yeah wow that's uh that's
pretty amazing thank you for going to
all that trouble I'm just curious if you
have no cell service at home and no
internet um are you able to listen to
this podcast regularly yes so I'm
actually a huge fan I'm a day one
listener I've been I've been living
rurally since 2018 without regular self
service at home and podcasts you can
download while you're in town and then
listen to them at home so they're my one
like real form of entertainment so yes I
definitely listen regularly oh that's
well first of all that's kind of I love
that I love that that's cool you know
it's it actually as a fan you're making
more of a commitment because how long a
drive is it for you to get from town to
home it's about 30 to 40 minutes I can
imagine you getting home after 40
minutes and you've got your freshly
downloaded uh Conor BR needs a friend
podcast and listening to it and going oh
God that wasn't worth 10-minute drive
maybe wait I have a question do you have
more than one podcast you listen to and
if so you must have limited time in town
what's the like ranking or priority of
podcasts that you download you know what
I mean yeah that's a good point I do
because I do have really limited S Serv
in town too so it takes a while to
download so I tried to do a mix of
comedy and then educational things I
used to just always have like um I
listen to True Crime a little bit but
now I have a toddler and no free time so
I can't really put that on the speaker
same with you guys and all of your
cockaroo jokes I've had to I can only
listen to it when he was asleep I know I
keep saying we should have an infant
friendly show a toddler friendly show
and um we're trying but we can never get
there is it a boy or a girl your child a
boy Gideon I have another one almost
almost here okay oh congrat congrat
ations uh I think Gideon needs to learn
about True Crime I think it's time
Gideon learned that there's bad people
out there and there's murders that need
salvin and so
uh two years superhero twoyear old yeah
well tell me a little bit about your
life because this fascinates me you were
living um out on a farm I'm guessing in
in rural in a rural part of uh Western
Virginia is that right West Virginia
yeah rural West Virginia um Southern
West Virginia my husband and I moved
here um with Gideon two years ago we
moved here to start a farm we're both
first generation Farmers so we're kind
of learning it as we go along together
we moved here from uh Northern
California after the Dixie fire so we
kind of uh just landed on West Virginia
and are are rning to live here that is I
I have to say I am very impressed
farming
is difficult it's really hard work it's
it's difficult and the fact that uh uh
that you and your husband are taking
this on I think is very cool and
impressive what kind of stuff are you uh
trying to grow on the farm thanks um so
we're hoping to get to the point of
self- sustainability right now we um
bees were our first major project we
have 13 beehives um we raise chickens we
have beef and um dairy cows we've had
turkeys
Ducks um we're just trying to get to the
point where we can either grow grow or
raise all of our own um food good God
that's very imp that is impressive to be
completely self- sustaining that is
something I will never achieve in my
life I need constant I don't know if I
will either but it's uh we're working on
it and especially right now I have to
say I'm less helpful in my third
trimester I've kind of taken a backseat
to all of the dirty farm chores well I
think you have a pretty good excuse I
have found that I my rules for survival
is there have to be four Whole
Foods within strolling within strolling
distance six
ATMs um a multiplex uh the list goes on
and on but these are just this is just
hardcore simple survival for me those
are the only places I will hike or Camp
there areas that have let me say I enjoy
a whole food for sure and the trader
does yeah it takes death uh I also need
soft serve ice cream available at the
drop of a hat
I need an REI nearby you can make your
own ice cream and then it's even better
and unlimited this sounds uh this sounds
impressive tell me about the livestock
you said you've got some real livestock
I don't know anything about cows nothing
I know nothing about cows I know that's
where the milk comes from and that's all
I know yeah so um I didn't know anything
either it's been a fun learning process
right now we have five cows so we have a
small herd um actually two of them are
cows which means that they um have had
calves so they are mil producers Betty
and Penelope we have two um that were
raising for beef Chestnut and midnight
and then we have one heer which means
she hasn't had a calf yet and then we
have two calves Bor or due this winter
baby season let me ask you a question
this may seem stupid but to the ones
you're raising for beef somewhere in the
back of their minds do they know yeah do
you treat them differently like you
don't get emotionally close to them like
a new recruit have they noticed that you
won't look them right in the eye you're
always hugging milk cows do they often
show you a picture of their girl back
home yeah and you're like I don't need
to see that yeah you know I hate to say
it but yeah they I think that there
definitely some emotional distance there
I make sure that they're happy but I try
not to get too attached maybe you'll
change your mind I would I would that's
the fear isn't that ironic though that
they have a shorter time on Earth they
should have a little bit more love in
that short time but you're starving them
that yeah okay well they're very happy
and my son goes out there he just loves
spending time with the cow so I think
they plenty of Love whenever I have to I
do have to say whenever I taste the meat
of an animal that grew up with a lot of
love it's terrible it's soft yeah it's
not good but there are steaks that I can
get and these are animals that never
knew true love and boy is that a tender
steak it's a delicious steak it's a
special restaurant I go to called
Loveless you know it's it's one to do
it's
it's these are free range chickens but
they never knew love real love
they were just raised in a 1950 Suburban
house yeah exactly oh I know where they
were
raised I'm kidding come on folks you get
it it's
funny